So in the bottom we see neon and this is a
small glass discharge tube
which has got a very low pressure of neon
inside it. It’s generally used
for lots of signs and things like that. You
might see ‘Fish and Chips’ or
perhaps a ‘disco’ or something like that.
So Neon is an inert gas like helium and it
doesn’t really form any
compounds at all. Most of you have probably
seen neon because it’s
used in these so-called neon signs where you
take a glass tube and put a
high voltage and it produces a red light.
So you can see that, again, a discharge, a
high potential discharge is
going across this tube and it’s exciting
all of the neon molecules inside,
such that we get this exciting, really vivid
red colouration.
And skilled glass-blowers can blow this into
glass shapes of signs saying
‘pizza’ or whatever on shops. You can
freeze neon at very low
temperatures about 10 degrees absolute and
early on in my scientific
career I did do an experiment in solid neon.
It produced a great result
with an iron compound and I’m still quite
proud of it several years on.
But it’s not really very important in terms
of absolute chemistry.
So this is just a simple pocket spectroscope
and it allows us to analyse
the wavelengths of light that each of these
individual light sources is
giving off. So each individual atom as it’s
excited in its emission zone can
give rise to different lines or different
frequencies of radiation or light
and we can use this little device to analyse
which elements are in each
of these different elements of light. So we
put it up to our eyes and we
look through, and we look at the different
colours of the lines in the
different gases.